now in recent days a new trend online
has provoked increasing concern from the
left and the media the trend is called
super straight
uh this is a new sexual orientation hot
off the presses
though not really new at all invented by
a tick-tock user in a video that has
since been removed
i'm not sure if he removed it himself or
tick-tock took it down
as hate speech certainly the left has
declared the video hate speech an
article posted to yahoo
bears the headline a social media trend
has people identifying as super straight
the transphobic campaign was meant to
divide lgbtq people
and pink news declares transphobic trend
super straight has links to the
far-right and neo-nazis
of course because everything does the
website distractify says
social media users explain how super
straight is transphobia
not a sexuality and the article comes
with a warning for those who didn't get
the message from the headline
that quote transphobic statements are
ahead
before i go any further um i guess we
should probably watch the video so let's
watch the video
that started all the commotion here it
is yo guys i made a new sexuality now
actually it's called
super straight okay since straight
people or straight men is myself i get
called transphobic
because i wouldn't date a trans woman
you know they're like would you date a
trans woman i'm like no
why that's a female uh no like that's
not a real woman to me like i want real
one no you're just transphobic
so now i'm super straight i only date
the opposite gender
women that are born woman so you can't
say i'm transphobic now
because that's just my sexuality you
know
uh pretty edgy stuff so the guy in the
video which
that yahoo article mentioned earlier
calls a hate and disinformation
campaign that's what they said about
that video it's a hate and
disinformation campaign
but he's really just making the point
that he's attracted to females which
means he's not attracted to males
even males who identify as female the
reason for this by the way is that
generally speaking
a human being is sexually attracted to
another human being
based on who that other human being is
not based on what perception the other
human has
of themselves the idea of being
attracted to another person's
self-perception seems absurd
incomprehensible because it is
now i'm not going to go around calling
myself super straight and i don't think
we should make any serious attempt to
turn super straight into a thing
simply because being regular straight a
normal old heterosexual
already means being attracted to members
of the opposite sex to the exclusion of
members of your same sex
even the ones who identify as members of
the opposite sex
coming up with a new term would seem to
surrender this ground and concede that
it's possible for a person to be
straight
and yet also attracted to members of his
biological sex
i don't want to do that so i'm going to
stick with plain old heterosexual to
describe myself but
this super straight thing is more of a
troll than anything else and as a troll
i have to admit it's it's pretty funny
and it makes an important point
and the point is pretty simple two can
play at that game
right if the left can go around
inventing new sexualities out of whole
cloth
then anybody can and if lgbt people can
express
pride in their sexual preference than
anybody can
one of the trending hashtags on twitter
right now is super straight pride
and many of the people using the
hashtags are accusing those who
criticize them of engaging in
super phobia now again it's silly and
really funny but the point is that if
you think this is silly then
all of the other invented sexualities
and genders are just as silly
and so is labeling someone transphobic
or homophobic for criticizing you or
disagreeing with you
the left does not want to add super
straight to the list of sexuality but
keep in mind
this is a list which includes but is not
limited to allosexual
androsexual asexual autosexual
bi-curious bisexual demisexual
uh fluid gay gray sexual
gynosexual heterosexual heteroflexible
homo flexible homosexual lesbian
pansexual queer
questioning sapiosexual sex repulse
scoliosexual and spectres yes
sexual um by the way a demisexual is
just someone who
uh needs to have an emotional connection
to someone in order to be attracted to
them
that's a demisexual if you if you need
you know if you need that emotional
attachment that emotional connection in
order to feel the attraction
so in other words women that's women are
demisexual
a sapiosexual someone who finds
intelligence attractive
and a gynosexual as the name suggests is
someone who's attracted to the female
body so in other words a straight man
or a lesbian an allosexual get this
an allosexual i'm not making this up and
i just found this out this morning
is someone who experiences sexual
attraction
okay if you're attracted to
anyone then you're an allosexual any
sexual attraction at all makes you an
allosexual
what this all means is that the super
straight community is selling itself
short i think i mean you could add a
whole bunch of additional labels
you could be a heterosexual allosexual
gynosexual super straight
this is how ludicrous it's gotten there
are there are
already lgbt orientations and pride
flags
for people who are straight but for
whatever reason don't want to call
themselves that
i say for whatever reason but i know the
reason the reason is that there is
privilege that comes with
being in the lgbt camp being under that
umbrella
okay it's not it's not it's not cis
heterosexual privilege
it's lgbt privilege that's what we have
in this culture
and that's why straight people invent
sexualities
i mean they they remain straight but
they invent new labels
just so they can fit just so they can be
in the club
and if you have a club that everyone is
desperate to be a part of that's a
pretty good indication that your club is
privileged
that's like the definition of a
privileged club
and all of these sexualities interact
with the ever-expanding list of genders
now this is certainly but a partial
catalog but that list includes
agender androgenin androgynous bigender
cisgender gender fluid
gender non-conforming gender questioning
gender variant gender queer intersex
non-binary pan gender trans female trans
male trans person
trans woman trans feminine trans
masculine to spirit and other
and like i said very partial list
matching up a sexuality with a gender is
like a march madness bracket they're
like
98 trillion possible outcomes and all of
these different words and labels are
only meant to obscure the fact that in
reality
you know it all still boils down to the
same basic quote traditional
possibilities when it comes to sexual
orientation
the leftist simply found a hundred
different ways to repeat itself
but they hasten to remind you only they
are allowed to do that
this is a game that only they are
allowed to play they can invent genders
invent sexualities express
great pride in their new creations you
cannot they say
you're not allowed according to their
rules and that's a very good reason to
break their rules and do it anyway just
to annoy them
i mean for no other reason so i'm a
supporter of the super straight movement
for that reason alone
in fact i think we could invent some
more i mean the sky is the limit
maybe we come up with um different
sexualities based on the day of the week
if you're attracted to somebody on a
tuesday you're a two's to sexual
if it's wednesday you're a wednesday
sexual of course fried sexual will be a
popular identification
i suspect there won't be a lot of
mundosexuals is this completely stupid
sure
but the people who talk about
demisexuals and allosexuals
you know have no room to criticize and
that's the point
two can indeed play at this game if you
don't like it
then maybe we should all stop playing it
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content